dear friends, we are here to talk about
soft power, so it is important to say right away that the
main
Russian invasion of Ukraine has put
at risk the very principle of what kind of power in
the world
it has become clear while some countries are learning to
negotiate and cooperate, there is an
aggressor country And when in the modern world,
anywhere  the appearance of an aggressor is a challenge
for everyone, because it means a review of all
international relations, everyone must
decide whether the language of aggression is acceptable
for him or not. That is
why I always emphasize that Russia
attacked not only Ukraine, it
attacked all world principles of peace at once  the
coexistence of human rights and
all the progress that we have achieved on this Plain,
why negotiate if you can shoot,
why conduct a dialogue if you can take it by
force?  at
the same time, something
very important happened,
something about which we are here now, because
unexpectedly for the attacker, the soft power of
Dalavitsich,
perhaps for the first time in history, it withstood
the blow of an entire army and only increased its
weapons of aggression, millions of people in Ukraine and
the world responded with cooperation,
solidarity, protection, help,
humanity
according to the study of soft power
presented today by the finance brand, over the
past year, Ukraine added the
most points in the rating of which power
among 120 countries,
how did it become possible,
of course, there is a huge contribution from our
friends from other countries, they opened up to
cooperation, they allowed it to happen.
You saw us  and we are you in your persons.
Thank you to your countries and compatriots,
one of the powerful manifestations of soft power
is culture, and it too has acquired a new
sound, starting from world
concerts in support of Ukraine to the
great celebration of the old age of Kyrylo in
debells in Carnegie Hall when the world
learned that it is Ukrainian  Shchedryk, in the
same way, the world got to know anew the
outstanding Ukrainian artists, whose
use of Russian symbols over the centuries
reveals Ukrainian history as a
part of the world and not of the Soviet or
Russian imperial
one.
about Ukraine, they
personify it, because every country is its people, to the
ambassadors of Ukraine,
it became itself.  not at all
Russian
and in all possible languages ​​we convey the
truth about what is happening in our country
despite the war and economic difficulties this
year we were present at important
international platforms from the field to
world parliaments we expanded cooperation
with a large number of institutions
We really wanted to return this violation to the world and
to ourselves  war, the feeling that
dialogue and humanity are much more effective
than economic and financial coercion
used by our enemy. That is
why we in Ukraine call the anniversary of the Russian attack
otherwise the
anniversary of resistance, solidarity, strength of spirit, the
anniversary of not only armed self-defense,
but also soft power.
Thank you for your support and I wish you
fruitful and interesting sessions.
Glory to Ukraine